one minute war zone rated 126 players
1774 rating time handicap 30-minute
tournament here we go
Oh tough start where's that little thing
over to your thing open Sicilian I think
I played this guy on the last stream
okay ooh you know what I'm going for do
I have to say it anymore do I have to
say it it's happening it's happening
H to or the bishop no just move how much
time was I gonna spend oh I'm in a pin
but it's okay I could play here whoa
they're piling up are they really gonna
take that guy I'm okay with this I'm
definitely okay with this definitely
okay let's go pawns dark Square
weaknesses everywhere sneaky tricks
watch out for the tricks they are not
only for kids watch out
uh-oh let's go King okay they forced my
hand let's go in the center and double
my pawns okay they have a passed pawn
but I have a central bishop and I have a
good King position my rook wants to play
over here this is far from a quick win
no quick wins in sight King position
were neck and neck here oh are you going
Knight
kill the knight why'd I do that
uh why'd I do that
oh I could get this pawn can I in this
King and pawn endgame where things are
gonna be okay where's that King going
hopefully I win this King and pawn
endgame I didn't do the calculations oh
no it should be okay 12 seconds though I
need time burners maybe run pond
grab a pawn over here okay the king is
cut off let's
get this guy rolling and this one get my
king up give a check actually and then
do this maybe give another check just
for fun wait what's the clock count oh
man let's check with check I'm just
gonna do that okay baby
oh I lost track of time
I gotta go quicker I got that one but it
was too close I didn't want the close
ones okay I got real nervous right there
oh okay there goes the f-pawn but maybe
I could target f7 soon okay they're
gonna be stopping that nonsense or are
they this is for free now and that
turned out to be a waste of time okay I
think I want to stop that b5 push and no
let's not do that Queen d2 Oh a night
right here hang on that Bishop get my
other rook to e1 and then play e5 Oh
serious weakness right now very serious
weakness that night is gone crazy
he just keeps moving what is going on
with the night wow he's getting some
exercise right there that night is
definitely an Ironman entered the
Ironman competition right there let's
play here and then Queen to age seven
the stamina
here we go making one pawn pusher I have
to watch out for Forks ooh
iPod needs to push to odd percent I
think in a move they're gonna move I'm
gonna take here and be on the bishop and
defend the pawn oh they missed it the
night is still excited about moving he's
still moving he's still moving his day
is over that's it no more Forks I'm
still a bit behind with time here let's
go here
where this night is coming over here fun
with the Knights variation let me tell
you everything
I just want to trade a little bit get
one pair off let's see can I get a fork
here gotta watch out for mates I think
this this Knight needs to get out of
here get out of here
wow did you just get out of here
Knight what a pain what a pain at night
how many Knight moans count them up Wow
finally get rid of that tricky Knight
okay now they are kicking it into a very
high gear right now let's go there let's
get behind this what does that rook up
to is up to no good
you have that pawn no time wow they're
booking they are booking right here okay
let's get out of the nonsense let's give
a check throw some checks in here for
black here right there geez where the
quick wins no quick wins finally back to
turn in 1708 Sal Ong way off to games in
the top guys for this okay this guy here
what do we have
okay 2191 Queen b3 Queen b6 you have the
LightSquared Bishop scum off or not okay
castle actually I'm gonna throw in Queen
b6 and then do a pawn push maybe I
should have done that sooner let's try
this I get an A for I have some control
over that square I want to preserve my
light square bishop now so the rope
doesn't come there but we have this
don't we I need to get rid of that
bishop hang on hang on bishop that's why
I played h6 Queen here Knight here and I
think I'm on c3 as well let me do this
actually I don't want night here
happening
you need to get rid of the glue and this
bishop is the glue get rid of that glue
okay there's gonna be an in-betweener
now finally oh okay the bishop is there
and now what we have more trades more
trades in the night is officially stuck
okay the bishop is the next piece I need
to get rid of so let's go with guard it
up on first and actually do what next do
King here and then king f7 Bishop d7
stuff or not
pigs get some pigs over here the rook
the bishop might play two eight three
one piece from like over there okay I'm
now I'm on it twice I'm gonna go for it
it's two minor pieces stop that and then
push okay now it's much clearer oh man
check push the pond push the pond and
then push the pawn again and then here I
have this square covered there is nope
Oh what am i doing I just drop stuff
what's the support oh man this is not a
good start at all where are the quick
wins they're not happening
nope just drop pieces okay they're down
on time that's all I'm getting my
opponents uh the time is just having to
run out it's just not good 21 and change
let's go I need maybe the help of my age
pond can he save this tournament we're
gonna see about that dark square
weaknesses may be a giant thorn he's a
giant thorn kick the pieces around get
out of there my queen wants to beware oh
this is a dead knight Knight takes
Knight here's available
oh I'm gonna take it actually with this
guy give up my rope to get this guy
Knight takes this oh this is a problem
there was a save exploiting this rook
being unprotected Bishop g2 Castle it's
still available not anymore though
Knight takes pawn was available Castle
gonna go after f7 actually let's get
that night out of here first and then
okay let's do this
and then this f7 is what I am after
right now I should maybe just move my
knight real soon I'm defending this pawn
amount f7 I want to get this bishop I'm
on the rook as well B 3 C 4 maybe e 6
intersection squares right here both
pawn or Knight could go to this square
look into those into your own game pawn
push with the four coming up bishop d5
then do this and then this note I'm
actually just any move back to
tournament 20s 36 33 30-27 I got four
games somebody has five in why play
checkers is here alright let's go with
okay we're having this are we
this structure get out there bishop I
get the bishop by force I believe no
okay now I do if I really want it I got
it okay I got that dark square bishop
and this pawn and the rook
oh is this a quick resign take the rook
and then run home where it's safe go
where it's safe kill the night castle
complete development Queen here grab a
pawn
grab that Bishop my knight wants to play
over here actually wants to get to the
dark square and that's gonna be coming
under fire oh the whole family's hit
whole family was hit right there queen
king and rook back to tournament 45
forty two thirty nine thirty five thirty
vous sur 19 minutes and change
okay still a lot of time in this
tournament okay we're having this they
eat to Castle I want to watch okay well
my my oh okay Oh dark squares here my
night wants to be on f4 actually yeah
that bishops gonna hit my clean okay but
Knight f4 is a serious problem I think
with Knight moves here eventually I'll
sign that Bishop I could consider that I
don't really have anything that rook
takes Bishop is a threat not anymore but
this is deadly now Forks cuz this pin
queen is dead ah are you kidding me you
can't see it on the screen but they
disconnected man it was a disconnect er
so what do you do when they disconnect
you do some homework oh and you wonder
how people have that high points it's
cuz they're winning quicker they're
winning more efficiently so come on
white come on Jackson Jackson's doing
good he's in check get him I have six
seconds left for my game okay I gotta go
back to it here we go Oh was Jackson
gonna win that game I don't know back to
tournament land here we go leaders
leaders leaders leaders leaders where we
at 42 I have 42 somebody has 53 okay
25 25 10 we're even mmm here play their
Castle run well run around with my
knight a little bit run night run night
run night dark squares let's see if this
is actually any good what's my bishop
even doing right here
okay that bishops gonna have fun or is
it and in between are very good that was
a good in-betweener right there if the
Queen's off the board maybe I'll be
happy with that I'm happy with it
definitely happy with that or am I
oh this is a problem that ponds hit too
many times and I can't defend it anymore
I could get this pond though maybe
arcanine okay this is nuts I got to come
over here and defend dark-squared
control dark-squared control
dark-squared control hopefully I have
enough of it what's happening here king
position King up tricky Knights tricky
Knights how can I make this work let's
go don't you dare get mated Oh
let's hit upon okay what's happening
it's opening up and I didn't want that
to happen
Oh dark squares dark square fun I think
right here is a good idea no my king is
gonna get chased away
is there a mate I better not fall for me
I'll scream oh I'm gonna scream I think
okay what do we have Forks if the pond
pushes I don't have I can't get that
pond I can't save that I can't get that
part
oh I can't even get them oh it's a dead
one it's a dead when it's a dead one oh
I hit down double the points after
histories that pond got too crazy oh I
liked my Knights positions too
ah that one stings oh let's go come on
you could still win this can't you can
you still win this please say you can
okay I think this is okay is it okay I
get the rook at the end of it right will
there be a quick resigner can i bounce
back quick somehow oh no oh no I can't
deal with the time tickers another time
ticker
oh okay wait I got this here and they're
gonna go after my pani you went after
the party and now I'm gonna go after the
kingi right they're not moving
okay here we go Queen on f6 are they
gonna castle maybe here first actually
oh I'm on the Queen come on come on
I have Queen here as well oh man okay
this is actually Maine back to China 54
is that kind of just beat me up there or
where is he
I forget his name mark mark all right
let's go go Knight f6 Knight c6 Center
get that pun that oh the night's gonna
play here actually that drop stuff Queen
here coming up mmm okay let's do this
I'm on the pond on the bishop I'm on the
bishop still oh I take with my night
otherwise they land in a fork here okay
it's going down it's gonna get hit with
the pond there and now what just get
developed right here my queen might be
deflected away from the defense of the
bishop I gotta do this and then what I
want to get out of that pin
they keep piling up on that get out of
there I wanna get that fish up and then
maybe trade okay let's do this and then
this even if it's wrong no not with the
Queen
okay just get behind here push that pond
and then target the G to square my
bishop could do that actually I want to
get rid of that pig get rid of that pig
before it's too late
two pigs they're bad news bishop here
coming up coming up I'm on the rook in
the pond oh they missed that one Pig
looking for another maids coming up by
force
check right here King over I gave a
check actually I could just go here me
back determined seventy I'm in third
somehow no I'm in fourth Oh
twelve minutes and change Stefanovich
efore oh this guy is up there he's got
86 open Sicilian Bishop to where Bishop
c4 okay Dragonland Dragonland Bishop e3
Queen d2 King side castle and now what's
the plan here I'm in trouble let's get
some trades in okay they're gonna take
my knight
the Knights gonna play there and now I'm
actually gonna back up and I want to get
out of that come over here and then get
rid of that dark square Bishop but I
can't do that so easily I would get
skewered I think let's do this Bishop h6
I think if I did that too early about
even on time let me take this and my
rooks want to do something else like one
of them come here and then pawn push and
then King up improvement in fact I want
to get in this move no I can't take that
that would have been bad okay now I
could do oh that King is getting really
active and I can't take that pawn
okay around this rook activity pawn push
over here a couple times now over here
rook activity rook activity is what I'm
looking for I want to get that beep on
check and then here have the B pun okay
well how they're gonna take that pawn
with that okay I have this to a two to
zero majority and my rook is gluing
everything together just push these
ponds and then get behind it keep going
keep going keep going
right here this is bad technique on my
end okay actually I could get that pawn
in this King and pawn endgame that pawn
might push no it's not this pawn is
there this is it plenty of time to win
okay they resigned back to term in 88
133 88 11 out of 11 133 way leg is right
on my heels having a good tournament
someone who has beaten me many times
five minute games that we've played is
this guy gonna move a non mover oh it's
a non mover I wait what can you do
there's nothing I could do this person
isn't moving where I'm dropping back I'm
in fourth fourth place
fourth place you don't get any of that
confetti if you're in fourth oh man they
got 103 103 153 oh man is this the guy
that beat me I forget the person's name
leaders this guy's going down on people
kappa right 153 my game has oh now
they're moving now they're moving and
they double the point so I'm actually
gonna get double the points here just
pre move anything just burn their time
time burners time burners anything just
don't get made it just don't get made it
don't take my queen either
oh there try for me check don't you dare
try me me I would have screamed if that
ever happened oh where am I at
where am i I have I have 108 I'm in
second oh no I'm in okay wait wait wait
wait wait leaders leaders leaders oh my
goodness 173 118 is in second 103 103
can I manage second nine minutes and
change Dan triple sevens okay we had a
good game in five minute earlier okay
now could I pile up on this guy this pot
is gonna be lost isn't it deadpan native
six
okay Queen c7 I should have done
actually I would have been on that night
a bit sooner and I think after b5 Bishop
here I could still try for fishing poles
I think it's actually a pretty good idea
let's go for it
I thought my queen is getting deflected
away from that I should have allowed
that I should have just taken the bishop
with my knight am i doing okay let's try
it again
get over here get over here I want to go
with this Knight so Michael my queen has
a clear shot and I'm still not gonna
give up on this idea actually moving
forward I want a knight right here next
okay wait wait wait wait wait I get this
in I'm on H two H two is on again Oh H 2
there it is back to tournament 138 173
138 133 123 oh we for V for some gambit
I don't want to really take that and get
the Queen's off the board gonna take
that pawn or not take the pawn a
recapture they're not gonna move they
are moving
maybe I should could take here twice
let's pin that Knight push here maybe
wide I back up I was thinking a six
that's why okay light square weaknesses
it's Castle first maybe getting a Knight
to f5 or if the Castle queenside
launched these pawns up here in fact I'm
gonna do that anyhow I guess they're
probably gonna go in that direction my
queen will be on that point and I want
to keep her okay if the knight was
playing there was gonna play here and
they kick the night away open this
position up oh this is matin - this is
good just move just move just move
anything
don't let your clock tick ah man okay
good good good I should have had that as
a pre moved back to tournament 158 193
158 six minutes and change it's possible
maybe maybe maybe maybe
if I could get paired up with the top
guy I think I would need that to happen
and I would of course be needing to win
that too needless to say right okay this
is a clear pond isn't it what is it now
they're gonna get it back okay well okay
they get that guy back and now we are
into okay I have this I'm gonna take
with my night so I could get my other
night to this square and it's probably
best to be challenged right away okay
well is this gonna come under some heavy
fire it is I'm gonna go here dark square
color for flight square bishop needs to
come out Queen c7 bishop here my other
up to c8 let's get that guy out of here
and target these C and D pawns
okay now the King there's checking
possibilities against the King for as
long as it sits on g2 unless the Queen
starts to control that diagonal so what
do you do here
double up maybe I'm that d pun know
there's a problem isn't there that pot
is falling pawn push I take and then
just play here and then he's hit three
times defended zero I do have a flight
Square and now I have a two-to-one
majority and it's just a clear pawn up
so this rook endgame clock situation is
good I maybe should have thrown in a
check now I could actually do it two to
zero majority and these guys even though
they move at a snail pace snail's pace I
can it's very effective once you get
these supporting moves in and I don't
want to allow that's sort of a flight
square thing to be covered with this
pawn might be up a pawn check somewhere
okay now it's this pawn push pawn push
pawn push let's go cut them off over
here right there at the down on time 178
213 178 no 233 I better just try and get
second
dan because there's somebody right
behind me in third French they're moving
yep they're moving here we go
all right the Queen gonna get trapped it
might if they're not careful or that
okay now queenside castle in case
there's a c5 break and I'm assuming that
that is going to happen the knight can't
capture oh they resigned back to
tournament the bishop should have
recaptured I think 198 198 four minutes
and change to 33 and 198 173 okay can I
get this one and maybe the next one
would have to be against the top guy
somehow can that happen and actually
even if it did come down to that it
probably wouldn't even finish there's
three minutes and 40 seconds left in
this game or in this tournament let's
just take that out and then get my
Knights working ok b5 actually let's get
my bishop here pawn push rook to e8 r b5
if I could get b5 in let's go here pawn
push again rook e8 or maybe even better
get my Queen here in my other rook to
this square pawn push Oh deadly fork
very nice combination be aware of that
not the first time I found for that
either
very nice very good very very very very
good
okay now stuff is hanging everywhere
this is dead and I'm a big trouble right
here my queen is hit I better not go
there let's try here oh man
Oh heavy fire on f7 pawn is pinned as
well Forks here maybe I'm in trouble
haha I'm a big trouble I am in big
trouble and I need to trade I think just
to relieve the pressure please I need to
pressure reliever here that pawns
falling but I get the bishop the pot my
pawns are following everywhere
Oh Forks everywhere okay let's go with
this one let's go with this one and
secure this position somehow come on
what's the clock situation hang on to
the rooks and the tricky Knight
whatever you do hang on to the tricky
Knight oh there goes the tricky Knight
he's dead you could win this can't you
oh there goes upon Primo's pre moves
amount of bishop I should have taken a
bishop and now I got the bishop give a
check card upon are they gonna grab my
pond right here pawn capture get out of
the way I don't want to trade look
behind here 1.2 anything back to
tournament 218 203 oh that guy could
catch me
oh I'm not gonna catch the top guy no
way
one minute 30 seconds remaining quickly
quickly
where we at I got to win this one with
how quick do I need to win this one
okay wait there might be fishing it
might be going fishing soon oh they're
wood they're getting that pawn let's
hang on hang on that this diagonal just
castle please 108 I gotta get I have 9
seconds to win this just castle just
castle here take that bishop 57 seconds
I have 6 seconds to win this somehow get
my knight here to check my other night
here f7 is mates right it's a mate
threat made threats still it's a check
here open this up I get that and open
this file up oh they took that piece I
don't stand a chance now or do I
there's no time there's only 23 seconds
like it up oh I got the Queen I got the
Queen I got the Queen are they gonna
resign they're not gonna resign what did
I get 300 uh who was it that passed me
right there somebody had 103 and then
they passed me right at the last game I
guess Oh 223 a Jules 273 223 218 I was
lucky to even get up there like that uh
good games ah